what's up man it's your boy bazaar man
check me out on the bootleg calf podcast
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here the legendary bazaar
welcome sir
what up dog how are you doing man i'm
looking at your plats man yeah well i'm
sure you got a lot more than me i mean
and you actually wrapped on mine i just
played this [ __ ] on the radio and they
sent me plexus like hey thanks play our
other [ __ ] too damn yeah like man play
this [ __ ] you actually were on the songs
you got yeah yeah yeah you actually did
something i didn't do anything all this
[ __ ] is i didn't i just played the [ __ ]
on the radio i broke you know bro break
records and [ __ ] damn what's your
biggest record you broke oh [ __ ] no
probably like
like early j cole early kendrick like uh
randomly enough macklemore i was playing
macklemore super early okay underground
hip-hop show oh he started off in the
underground mac lemme yeah
okay yeah okay some real backpack he
like you know yeah hipster [ __ ] hipster
rap
[ __ ] hipster rap at its finest damn
yeah young mac what's going on with you
man man trying to be a hipster man i
respect it it's a nice like uh
late life decision to pivot to yeah man
i'm going through different
personalities it's my history
personality so you're in hipster mode
of bazaar's career right now are we
changing the are you singing about uh
trans rights and stuff wow you're
changing it up yeah i gotta change it up
man the new millennium man do you feel
like
when you listen to your music at times
like from like back in the day and even
you know newer stuff
it's obviously
you'd be saying some wild [ __ ]
especially like vintage d12 [ __ ]
because i always think like damn
like i always like talk to artists about
like just kind of the state of how
sensitive everybody is nowadays i'm like
yeah i don't know if marshall mathers lb
could happen in 2022 like i don't know
purple purple pills could happen in 2022
or devil's night like is that uh do you
ever like listen to your old [ __ ] and be
like damn
i was saying some
wild [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'll be forgetting halfway should i
be saying man what do you think is like
the craziest line you've said on a song
that you think might like if it if it
came out today would get you in some
serious [ __ ]
uh
i don't know maybe uh you know what my
hands are so numb
mm-hmm my mother sucked my dick and i
didn't come hmm that's one of the
raunchy ones
i don't know any [ __ ] about kids
probably would be
probably super offensive yeah anything
about it you'd be like harry spears
who's irish spirit you saw he's he did a
bit he did a bit about kids like 12
years ago they're trying to cancel him
now for it because it's like being
rehashed
damn him and tiffany haddish are in the
skit in like 2012.
and people are mad about it all like out
of nowhere oh wow yeah erie spirits
let's do
he does all the impressions okay yeah
great he does great impersonations his
jay-z impersonation is insane his dmx
one is though yeah yeah then they trying
to cancel my man get him out get his ass
out of there it's crazy man it's crazy
nowadays like uh how would you say like
you know
being bizarre knowing that you're kind
of
like
i feel like when people listen to
bizarre they're expecting a certain
level of like shock value
is it like a little harder to deliver
that how you'd like to nowadays
uh
well i think i'm being a little bit more
lyrical now
with the shock but i still stick my
little punches in there man i think it's
my that's just my my brain is wired man
right so i'm a little bit more sneaky
with the punches but they still they're
still they're still flagrant they're
still funny yeah
yeah your [ __ ] was always hilarious yeah
i feel like you could have did stand up
yeah you know i'm but i'm trying to
scale back a little bit uh
i say
one to two like i think i said something
about a little nausea
he ain't important
especially after he didn't get that
abortion
oh cause he was pregnant yeah about me
yeah
he was a pregnant male
it was a nice rollout hey it was a good
rollout
hey had people talking you wrote a bar
about it worked right damn yeah so i'm
still sneaking a man yeah
i don't think people take my [ __ ]
serious man i think i i think they kind
of know you're like yeah
other people can't say what i say yeah
if someone if someone else said that
it'd be a problem but i feel like people
expect that level of like comedy or like
at least like they're not gonna take it
like personal if you say it but what if
i'm serious well i don't know and you
could have stopped to help me before i
really
committed a serious crime well that
would be crazy i couldn't stop you
yeah you could have talked to me yeah
this guy over here with the mullet is
that's his job
love man he's juiced up off bay oh man
oh he want to talk about his red bull
that's it
this guy smoked two packs of black and
mild a day a hundred percent man um i
was just telling you i spent some time
out in detroit uh recently and uh
man i really was doing in detroit
hanging out with uh we shot with soda
baby out there uh on the east side we
were with pablo giovanni on the west
side we were with uh we were with uh i
swear vezo he was shooting his movie
so we just stayed out there for a week
and just shot a bunch of stuff for above
all and it was it was fun man i enjoyed
it a lot okay i don't know what to
expect because you hear like you know
you gotta come [ __ ] with us next time
when you come to the demon what part of
detroit are you from from seven mile
evergreen okay is that the east side or
west side just the west side okay
deep deep west uh deep west side i know
like there's like a bit of a vibe change
from the west side east yeah what do you
think the vibe is well from what i would
say that like the west side seems a
little from what everyone has told me is
a little bit more of the flashier
hustler
that's where the east side's a little
more like you know
grimy maybe you know what i'm saying
like
so i don't know i i really uh
the food was cool i told you there's a
[ __ ] coney island on every corner did
you go to starters
i don't think i did okay
i just know we was just pulling up the
coney islands
[Laughter]
that was like everybody we'd go to their
hood they'd be like we got to take you
to our coney yeah cause that's that's
that's a real big thing in detroit uh
you know
what coney do you go to
right because you know you know you ask
me what's my favorite coney is
lawns coney island on seven mile okay
and that's because we got this omelette
called the seven mile omelet ooh
and basically they put everything in a
whole store in it inside the almond yeah
hash browns all type of sounds like a
movie
yeah that's your go-to chili the chili
you know the chili from the uh chili
cheese yeah they put the chili inside on
it too that sounds like [ __ ] diarrhea
though
that sounds like a [ __ ] problem for
the [ __ ] toilets oh man and then we
were super cliche
yeah
we were driving through nikki d's uh
drive-through okay
two o'clock in the morning no it was
this was like 1 p.m because we had to
shoot at like two
and they were like go to nicki diesel
it's right over here and then we this
was the first time we had been on eight
mile road right so i'm like fresh and
this was like our first day in town yeah
so i just did you did you notice the
potholes oh yeah okay okay cool so i'm
just [ __ ] blaring
eminem in the [ __ ] drive through just
being like the most stereotypical right
white dude who's on vacation
i was doing it to be funny but then we
actually drove to the trailer park
the eight mile trailer park and that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up
i was like this is crazy
this [ __ ] is depressing
yeah a game they're like yeah it was
like some toothless lady smoking
she's on the corner i'm like hey which
one was eminem she's like you see that
empty lot right there it was right there
they tore it down
wow i was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] up over there man
man that's what he shot the movie yet
yes where they shot the movie at man did
they take you on seven mile in dresden
i don't know we're everywhere that's
another house where he lit up in detroit
they didn't no no i just drove i just
drove by we just googled uh eminem
trailer park and just went in oh yeah
you know many people come from like all
around the world just to see a bomb
i'm sure from overseas germany i'm sure
i'm sure and it's probably not the
safest place to just be hanging out at
right
what you think
i would say based on my experience all
the places we were at were we're not too
far from eight mile and we were in some
pretty hairy areas yeah like yeah
probably like y'all's on seven mile and
and crashes we're all over the place man
yeah but uh but yeah i would say you
know probably not the
the smartest thing i did do the uh
mom's spaghetti restaurant was [ __ ]
just terrible
i went for them on spaghetti it wasn't
good man i i wanted to like it you
italian ninja nom okay i'm just pl i'm
german and irish i can't tell what you
is because you ain't got the mustache
german and irish bro german irish boring
white
okay
i feel like if you're italian there's
like some sort of like no i'm not white
i'm italian right what
german and irish is like that's like
crazy you're a crazy [ __ ] that's
just white as [ __ ] that's like it's
about as boring of course i mean only
thing i can say others like being
english okay yeah you know what i
appreciate about you is that you are uh
as a black man in hip-hop you fully
embrace caucasian humor
[Laughter]
damn
huh
because you know i can't i have joke in
front of my homies and they'll call me
gay you know oh okay they'll be like yo
you're [ __ ] wild what the [ __ ]
wrong with you oh you said i can
appreciate it i'm saying your humor to
me i feel like has always been very
similar to mine okay very dark [ __ ] up
yeah we bust this [ __ ] up people at at
times questionable yeah definitely
questionable yeah like are there certain
jokes you can't get off with certain
homies that you can get off with that
guy
oh yeah he laugh at anything
yeah he laughing baby i keep him
laughing man so i can't really truly
trust on him what's going on with the
music [ __ ] right now what do you got
going on man um
absolutely nothing nothing
no man no man i just uh
i just dropped the album call he got a
gun
great name yeah
and uh i i did the whole album with my
man fire mother over there the guy with
the mullet
he's the producer yeah oh he's here okay
yeah he did the whole album from
beginning to end
so i had really lost the love for
hip-hop for a minute i wasn't really
[ __ ] with it mm-hmm so uh my boy ken
gordy introduced me to this guy
sharokina gordy yeah yup yup and troy
trey legend van nikon harper
and uh this guy here he was just so pure
on hip-hop like i mean this
i mean this guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
about nothing but recording right
so he had the like typical old school
basement six dogs four cats his girl
cooking for cats yeah damn this girl
cooking a meal
his kids jumping around crazy just how's
it smell oh man
that sounds like awful
[ __ ] up house
six dogs four cats
food's getting made and there's kids
cats eating on the counter all that [ __ ]
you know
i'm not surprised
but it
it was an environment that i needed man
so
you know he he brought that old you know
i'm saying that old bizarre back to the
battle rap bizarre wow before the crazy
sick rape is bizarre the crazy sick
rapist bizarre yeah yeah
so i'm proud of this album man you know
what i'm saying we uh
we just been i had to move in this
basement for two months
you lived in this basement with the cats
and the dogs yep damn
shout to gertie his dog his dog
and so
while living there you finished the
album yeah nice yeah man it was a long
process too man cause you know he
records on acid bro
are you from are you kidding are you
engineers familiar with that are you
kidding
serious yes
what year what can we help cyrus before
he leaves
can we get him a crack
let's just get him let's get him a crack
for pro tools or something i haven't
heard sony assets since high school
we'll get bro we'll get you a nice jump
drive
we got to get you around
okay i i still have to send it to your
boy on pro tools you're not going to get
off that easy man
sony acid
wow
salute to you man that's he's been on it
since like uh 73
something since [ __ ] the internet
started right
but he still got aol
but
it gives the the rawness of the album it
gives us the sound it gives it a grit it
gives us the
hunger right his house felt like
a bunch of tears that went over there
and we caught the bus over there to do a
song and [ __ ] nice
you are
i feel like sometimes people don't
realize like that you did come from the
battle scene that you were like i feel
like we think of your bars as like you
know
very funny but i feel like
in that it's your your skills as an mco
probably aren't respected as as they
probably should be do you feel like this
project you kind of
yeah definitely definitely definitely
yeah cause uh you know when i was in d12
i had like a
a role to play a character you know what
i'm saying
and and marshall he really liked it the
deep voice
yeah so
like sometimes a d voice would would
have me to
he would be worried more about the
you know i'm saying the funny [ __ ] then
really the line on the syllable or some
[ __ ] like that so
yeah so would you say you were kind of
like hey look your role is to do this
exactly you are the fun you're the
comedic relief of the crew you're gonna
say the most wildest most outlandish
[ __ ] and it's gonna be okay because your
name is bizarre i've been saying wow i
landed [ __ ] but like but in the most
simple way yeah in the most simple way
yeah right put that away so this
this um mom his beats inspired me to let
all his [ __ ] is like straight gutter
boom bap [ __ ] so you was back on your i
was back on my [ __ ] yeah 100 hell yeah
no girlfriend
drama free
cmos boxing
[ __ ] young hoes
nice cmos yeah i just the pills do you
like
the raw seat i just threw the pills that
that you could get no i do uh minus mix
with the
damn i forgot
no no not elderberry something else
have you noticed uh it's like a sugar
taste set is it like this oh it's like
the jelly in the jar silly sap or
something i know
yeah yeah it's like a yeah yeah i know
you have to eat it
dude yeah i had to i just did i can't
eat that [ __ ] i do black students i just
do the pill
it's it's probably not as as beneficial
but it's yeah it's still good black sea
monster it's it's it's it's it's like
energy yeah that's all i need i'm like
let me pop one of these boys a day you
know what i mean do you feel like it you
you notice like your health getting
better like oh you started [ __ ] with
cmos hell yeah yeah shout out to dr sebi
man yeah we gave you way more energy you
know i used to be narcoleptically just
falling asleep every [ __ ]
yeah yeah i don't do that [ __ ] no more
yeah would you say like uh you're the
healthiest you've been
uh right now yeah yeah because you look
healthy you look like you've lost weight
i had it i had a um i had a minor stroke
too
then i had the attic you don't want to
get on my [ __ ] yeah i had stopped taking
my medicine for like two months was the
reason you had a stroke due to like
lifestyle [ __ ] or was it just something
like you you
i had i had became vegan
and uh basically stopped taking my
medicine and tried to do it natural and
that probably wouldn't that wasn't a
good idea without concern with the
doctor
i feel like people go vegan
but they don't understand that there's
like downsides i didn't understand it i
was doing it because
i was dating a girl that was doing it
i'm a [ __ ] follower no no she i no
but yeah i
she was getting healthy from it you know
what i'm saying so i try to do it but i
didn't know why i was doing it right
you're just doing it to do it yeah so i
started getting on the road doing them
shows
and then at night time it's three four
o'clock in the morning you high you got
the munchies so all i know is if i go to
just when i go to mcdonald's all i know
is i can't eat no burger but i can't eat
all the fries hell yeah fries hash
browns chips
rice donuts all cars all
carbs so my friend over there who's
switching the cameras is a vegetarian
but he's full of [ __ ] because all he
does is eat potato chips french fries
and
like literally what you're saying is all
he eats
he just eats bean and cheese burritos
okay
nachos okay
[ __ ]
bags of doritos the purple ones right
any type of chips he's tried so if you
ever need a good snack he'd be like yo
you're gonna try these chips those are
gas but he eats like an absolute
dumpster fire but you know he's
vegetarian so when he says it's a girls
it sounds better the problem is he's
still not getting no [ __ ] so oh wow
so i think cyrus should go full meat
again do we think we should get him back
to full meat yeah i've been trying to
convince him
i i can't can you
become a mediterranean meatatarian bro
he'll [ __ ] up a whole baby embryo from a
chicken so he's been just ordering
cheese pizzas and [ __ ] yes and knowing
anybody gonna ask him for nothing and
then he'll go to he'll go to subway and
get a foot long sandwich with just the
veggies on it oh wow i'm like you're
sick man
wow my thing is is if you could eat the
aborted baby chicken what you could eat
the chicken meat
what's that what an egg is
it's a chicken embryo he'll [ __ ] up some
chicken babies oh yeah but he won't [ __ ]
up the chicken meat yeah that's a good
ass go damn
aborted baby chickens
i never think where's their rights
peta oh i guess that their priority for
they are fighting for them i'm sure they
just they're probably throwing blood on
the floor of like a chick-fil-a right
now somewhere
kev i know you was just sick man i'm
[ __ ]
[ __ ] man
i'll say i'm gonna hit bizarre we're
gonna have a good [ __ ] time man
you're gonna have a great [ __ ] you
just became this sick guy all of a
sudden
not all of a sudden
it's been a long time man it's been a
long [ __ ] time bro um any features on
the new album uh yeah uh
who you don't know uh
got a song with cool keith oh shout out
to cool kids yeah shout out to you
whenever you come back to planet earth
if we shoot the video for it cool keeps
that guy yeah
cool keeps a guy but he i don't know
where he's at right now he's in mars
yeah
he's cool keeps getting cool keys yeah i
got a uh nibs [ __ ] your life gorilla
gorilla names was just here last week
yeah
conan he's from coney island you guys
like coney island he's been in detroit a
lot of times he know why laconia he
almost signed with eminem he had like an
opportunity where he could have got on
shady but you know he had some [ __ ]
happen in his life
yeah he went to uh
prison for a minute yeah yeah
it's after my boy names man i've been
knowing i do for a long time what i love
is his he also has very
disrespectful
[ __ ] on your album oh yeah he's saying
something well he probably he was like a
bizarre to this feature i'm going to say
the wildest [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah he said
the covey line though it might be
unacceptable what do you say oh man he
said uh what'd he say
he said something about [ __ ] you can
get this
game i gave my mama gave my mom and my
sister some cover for christmas
that's fine some [ __ ] he said
yeah
then i got young z on the album oh young
z from the outside
that's old school yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i got a they're from uh jersey right
newark yeah i remember that yeah uh
guilty simpson from detroit [ __ ] man i
had guilty simpson on my show in 2010
man i haven't heard that name in a long
time yeah yeah that's a detroit you know
it's crazy because detroit there's so
many like uh players genres of detroit
hip-hop so like when i was growing up
obviously eminem
d12 was like oh we choice oh we tried
but then there was
slum village there was j dilla there was
black milk there was guilty simpson
there was all those guys obviously royce
it was it and then now like detroit's
like low-key like
top two or three hottest city in all of
rap music everyone's getting signed out
of detroit the street [ __ ] coming out of
detroit is crazy yeah
doug
who's like a detroit right now i [ __ ] a
baby money who just came up here he just
said yeah that's my boy from 12th street
yeah vezo is probably my favorite uh
i love um
i think baby tron's got really funny
like one lines yeah his dad was signed
to psychopathic records which is funny a
lot of people don't know that yeah uh
you you in tune
yeah uh
yeah i mean 42 doug those i would say
he's so big that like yeah yeah you got
to get him out of the underground yeah
but he's [ __ ] hard bro yeah for sure
his voice is insane right his tone is
crazy yeah we grew up with his daddy's
dad was a cheddar boy he saw each other
boy shout out to the eastside cheddar
boys yeah yeah shout out to shout out to
cute man i i just checked out because i
met little blade uh blade icewood son
out there okay and uh i just checked i
actually just got around to finally
listening to this [ __ ] his [ __ ] is cool
shot low blade obviously payroll
giovanni's going crazy but he's been
going crazy for [ __ ] years
um yeah not detroit is detroit's going
up right now man yeah like qc just
signed vezzo and they had signed baby
money so qc is tapping in heavy yeah
yeah
i'm proud man we're going crazy man yeah
well do you why do you think there was
such a a big divide in like the genres
of detroit hip-hop because it would feel
like you would listen to even like say
eight to ten years ago
uh you would listen to like doughboy's
cash out and they'd be so different than
what was going on with like maybe a
black milk or even like a big sean you
know what i mean yeah
i mean you know i think it ain't really
no division because we all [ __ ] with
each other it's just that it just
i think the hip-hop
part popped first
so you know what i'm saying that's all
people really knew detroit for was yeah
like you said jay dilla
and uh
and royce yeah rory slum and then d12
eminem
so then but it was always the gangster
[ __ ] that was there it's just that
it hadn't you know it wasn't popping
like it is now but it still was rock
bottom uh
you know saying may west mm-hmm hell of
a hell of a is a you know he was in a
group back in the day so but the
gangster she just didn't take off like
the other [ __ ]
yeah because we got detroit we got a
certain bounce it's a certain
flow pattern if you notice they all and
they all stay we all stay in a certain
pocket right yeah that's real that's
real
i noticed that and then there's i mean
some of the greatest rappers of all time
i mean em royce elzai jesus christ yeah
i was like might be correct but we gotta
we gotta we gotta branch that division
together between the young and old do
you feel like m has
could be doing a better job of that
because i feel like when i talk to the
because i i'm friends with a lot of the
young guys in detroit and i feel like
they feel like such a disconnect
from em as to where like a guy like big
sean he just had that cipher at the end
of his album where he put everybody on
that [ __ ] like sean's been doing
rivers with a lot of people do you feel
like m could maybe do a better job of
maybe like tap it in with like the
movement in detroit right now
i'ma work on that i think it's my job to
do that you know what i'm saying
m is a you know very private person you
know what i'm saying rightfully so i
just think you
know detroit is so small i just
sometimes we
we forget how big of a story he is
you know what i'm saying because i
i think about like a question like this
like
like do you think every rapper from
brooklyn
no jay-z no but i do know give you a
similar example okay so let's rewind
2009 2010 2011 la hip-hop right at the
time there was glasses malone there was
an ipsy hustle
there was all these guys from la
um
that were doing dope [ __ ]
but
at the time
specifically like a guy like nip like on
my show he like there was like
i wouldn't say animosity but there was
definitely some sort of feeling that
like damn
like dr drain [ __ ] with us
like the the og's at la ain't
acknowledging what we got going on now
obviously
two years later drake put his arm around
kendrick lamar and the rest is history
so i just think that like i think
sometimes like you know
i think i think a lot of it i'm gonna be
honest with you bro i've been around all
these of course superstars my whole life
i think
through all these greats
dr dre's and eminem
they all got they all got one of those
middlemen dudes that tap type of man
like for dre
it was mike lynn
you know i'm saying mike lam probably
brought half of
mo or not more than half of the artists
at aftermath right so you know some
great great artists have gone through
that label yeah a lot of them went
through mike lynn
so
i think you know
definitely with marshall you know what
i'm saying i'ma just
i'm gonna tap him in a little bit more
you know what i'm saying because i know
i know this he's willing to listen and
[ __ ] is special right now i feel like
it's at an all-time high yeah i just
think that he he's so busy into doing
his own [ __ ] you know i get it he's
interesting
you gotta yo check out this he's a
conglomerate let me show you baby money
you know what i'm saying
because other than that if if me royce
of denial already shown
you know what i'm saying he's working so
hard you know
it would probably won't be away so
i think the ogs and i'll take personal
personally on this to bridge this gap
you know what i'm saying
because i know all of them i know the
the piezies and the solders and the best
chocolate pizzas i didn't mention him
earlier it's crazy yeah i know all right
shout out to flint too
young man yeah shout out to rio man
shout out to all flint
hey what ups bootleg kev we got to stop
the interview to tell you what our good
friends at my bookie football season has
started my favorite time of the year
cause i love to gamble on football it
makes watching football so much fun it's
my like literally i just love watching
football and i love it even more when i
got money on the line and no matter
where you are right now what state what
country you can get in on the action
it's a winning season go to my bookie
sign up for a new account register and
get that double deposit bonus using the
promo code bootleg now let me tell you
what that means that means when you go
to my bookie let's say you make a 250
deposit using the promo code bootleg
you'll have 500 to gamble with that's
right they're gonna double your [ __ ]
money right now they got the prop
builder you could bet on uh whether or
not i don't know
well matthew stafford throw for three
touchdowns will kylo murray rush for a
touchdown you could put all those on one
thing and secure the [ __ ] bag
all right get online with your boy let's
get this money together my bookie go
sign up with that promo code bootleg and
double your deposit right now go
register michigan got a movement man
weed is legal out there now oh man i'm
hiding the [ __ ] right now
i said they got that that's the place
they got it right they got man right
house out there for like five thousand
real quick
you know what's crazy is when they were
like [ __ ] 500 i should have bought
one was that like eight years ago you
could get a house out there for like
nothing it's crazy but it's you don't
want to house a file and they they
taking the furnace well it's crazy
though it's crazy well you know shout
out to danny brown danny brown had a
song um
uh called a scrap or die
and the entire song is about
detroit and like the culture of like
stripping houses of all the stuff yeah
that's that's some real [ __ ] yeah
yeah my my cousin brought a house
and uh
he had to have his homies
stay in the house
just for him to because he dropped one
load off of his of his [ __ ] he had to go
back and get the other load right he had
to have some people stay in the house
just to make sure
the first load was still there
and
because you can sell all that oh yeah
right off the rip that's just crazy it's
like the catalytic converters right now
yeah oh yeah that's a lot are they doing
that in detroit right now yeah yeah you
get 1200 you're doing that everywhere
you get you get a catalytic converter
off somebody it's straight money
wherever you yeah i think i think
there's like 1200 or some [ __ ]
there's no shortage of catalytic
converters to junkyards right now i'll
tell you that damn crackheads is
bringing in things 10 at a time my guy
that's a lick
for sure
for sure yo um
when you think back uh
and you think of
like your time with d12
um
by the way devil's night yeah
[ __ ] incredible project uh
i think uh i think of like
vmas i think like mtv i just when i
think of mtv i think of like the purple
hills video
what was your craziest recording session
during the d12 days when you guys were
working on those projects
uh
craziest sessions oh man those are like
[ __ ] strippers was it oh no man
it was a lot of work man it's a lot of
work i i think we had fun after the
studio but
[ __ ] you know being in the studio in man
sometimes you could you might be in the
booth for five six hours wow doing one
verse over
he was such a perfectionist yeah he was
on your ass so like you had to he had to
make sure hey look i'm on this
[ __ ] with y'all y'all gotta make
sure he gets sick man i mean
i mean one time he got so sick with it
man i went home he he wanted me to do
some ad-libs over
and uh
i guess he can't wait for me so i came
back the next day he had did him for me
did they stay on there he he sounded
just like me my voice and i was like bro
you are sick
you are sick man
that's crazy yeah was his uh his writing
process like we hit like nowadays
a lot of the newer artists they punch in
so they just do line by line and they
don't really write anything down yeah
which i think there's like positives and
negatives to that yeah um
positives you probably get a lot more
done okay i think negatively like you
maybe
each line maybe don't count the way it
should yeah because you're coming up
around the spot but like what was was em
always out of the notepad
yeah always off the notepad yeah he feel
like if he if he ain't um
for like
he feels like he's the top obvious
opposite of me
i don't write raps
unless i'm going to the studio
it has to be a beat someone should play
on just i don't have you don't have like
notepads or [ __ ] like you asked me to
spit at 16 right now i couldn't
yeah because you don't have the beat
playing no i know i don't even know
nothing i don't even know the number oh
[ __ ] that's cool you don't remember any
of your old lyrics no i have to ask the
other group members on stage right
before the court is coming soon
really yeah yeah yeah all the time yeah
so
yeah man
but him
he feels like
he's wasting the engineer's time
if he don't have anything prepared
and it's his studio and he's paying the
engineer yeah
yeah
what do you feel like you know so he's
just got the notepad ready to go yeah
you know and i i remember when
some advice that he gave me that that i
never followed but i should have
followed this [ __ ]
he said man sometimes just go over the
verses over and over again like when you
take it home
and you say and ask yourself
did i say the dopest line right here
could i could i have said something
better right here
and if you think you could've you know
what i'm saying changing
you know what i'm saying or
but i never listened
i'm like [ __ ] that i'm going back to the
hotel but it's [ __ ] for 10 hours
oh those those days on the road had to
be crazy oh man a blur man i bet yeah
our [ __ ] was like well you know the one
the one good thing about me that
balanced me out is i had a record out
before d12
called attacking the widows so
i at least i i did get that underground
experience
i i struggled i did all the shot i went
to new york
it was [ __ ] nowhere to stay slept in
cars eight dollar slice pieces
struggled 90s an underground rap life
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i did that [ __ ] so you know so when
we signed with marshall i mean it was
just like
boom instant you know you already kind
of like i'm used to this [ __ ] anything
that but we got hotels we good some a
couple of guys hadn't
experienced that they went straight from
to to private jets you and proof like
the most experienced in the group prior
i mean outside of england yeah yeah yeah
yeah proof proof was uh
signed to this label called
mari uh maurice malone the clothing
design he was signing i remember maurice
malone yeah for closing the brain yeah
proof was signed to him
and uh i was signed a federation record
shout out to rico oh wow and uh yeah so
we we was pretty seasoned
but you know
so uh we had that underground experience
but
you know when we signed a shady man it
was straight private jets
was the formation of d12 prior to eminem
being in the group or was it something
that happened
like at the same time
no d12 happened before
eminem uh you know yeah eminem was in
the group
from the beginning it was six of us
you know i'm saying and but no it was
supposed to be 12 of us my bad probably
12
but we never could find 12 members to
stick with us
so you know there's a lot of ways to
come yeah yeah that's a lot of people
right yeah
yeah so we made it six rappers with two
personalities
i actually like that yeah everybody's
got two personalities yeah 12 people 30
dozen yep there you go there it is and
it and uh
it was the redundant but uh
a rock band out of um maryland had the
name oh
d12 is dope though so we had to change
it to d12 yeah was there anybody uh who
we may know of any notoriety from the
detroit area that almost made the group
but didn't
i that was i almost was in d12 yeah you
know he was in it for a minute but you
know
he you know i didn't know that
going off doing his own thing i don't
even think he ever came to session but
he he definitely was was down with us
damn i might be mine if else if i'm
lying please don't strike me down man
you know if elsa
elsa and eminem going back and forth on
records would have been oh yeah
oh yeah and he ended up in slum village
yeah
that was crazy too yeah
yeah cause he he ended up in like a what
was that like the third version of slum
village
so many moving parts yeah it was a lot
man yeah it was hard to keep up with to
be honest yeah yeah it was it was a lot
going on yeah it's crazy too because you
came from like you know obviously in
detroit there's this there was this
other era of like horror core rap kind
of right right you think of like uh
ken gordy uh obviously the psychopath
record [ __ ] um that was his other like
this whole other thing going on out
there at the same time that you kind of
also
were like privy to as well you
personally yeah obviously yeah yeah that
movement like like
obviously
i want to get to the icp beef but okay
uh i'm i'm curious like uh
was was there like a
that scene of detroit hip-hop that was
like more like really underground like
i don't know if it's horror core but you
know what i mean
the icp the isham the king gordy [ __ ]
you know yeah that they had like they
had his own lane of his own
you know what i'm saying and uh and it
was very specific to that area and i'll
be honest with you
i already never knew nothing about that
world until
i started [ __ ] with king gordy
because ken gordy was signed a fpt which
was the same production company
marshall assigned to
so that's how we met ken gordy
and then i started [ __ ] with him and
we started doing our projects
he he was already kind of in in the in
the jugular world so he kind of
you know introduced me to it so it was
nothing like i never that i sought after
i kind of i grew up with hip-hop boombap
of course and it was like it's kind of a
it's kind of a weird world you know to
be honest right right yeah definitely
yeah the juggalos here they yeah they're
all grown up now yeah you i've i've yet
to
i've yet to meet like a 17 year old
juggalo like now like these days you
know
like you're all like
right 37 right
minimum yeah right it's still out here
rocking oh it's crazy though cause like
you know i'll say this about them they
really
uh
revolutionized merch
yeah they revolutionized being
independent definitely they did some
things that a lot of people are
practicing nowadays i think that they
helped
show like guys like tech nine the way
and strange music the way yeah you know
so
but when you guys had your back and
forth by the way some of the best skits
ever
ken connect from connecticut [ __ ] all
that [ __ ]
and i definitely was not a big icp fan
growing up i thought that [ __ ] was
terrible but i've gone to their shows
like i've had faygo fly by me they used
to launch feigl in the [ __ ] crowd
yeah they gather um but uh
uh how crazy did that ever get was that
anything other than just being comedic
or being like just some rap [ __ ] some
90s rap beef [ __ ] or was it ever like oh
no no it got serious yeah how serious
did it get um
it was serious like old site if we see
them they see us it's whatever
and i think they ran into marshall at a
car shop or some [ __ ] like way back in
the day
i forgot what happened but
yeah it was it was it was it was serious
man i remember one time uh
we had a show at st andrew
and uh i guess icp
had like a talent show or something in
the basement and what we was performing
up top and we didn't know each other was
going to be there
and uh i just remember they fans
they their fans gave it away because
they did
before
no not even they was just giving us the
meanest like the dirtiest [ __ ] looks
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
why everybody why did you [ __ ]
keep looking at me
everybody was like
icp in the basement i'm like oh
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] but i think they end up
squashing the beef that day okay and
trick trick and uh vitaj yeah damn
that's crazy because that sounds like a
hairy situation yeah you guys are
upstairs there downstairs in the middle
of a beach yeah yeah i could have gotten
first time we ever seen each other over
the years was your situation with eshom
did it have anything to do with with the
icp thing because i know he was over
there for a little bit it was just
something separate nope uh
i know but i think ishaan you know
i think each time his thing was
marshall was showing him
respect by saying he was a cross between
icham and nazi
and um i don't know i think because he
took that disrespect or whatever and
which is a crazy thing to take yeah yeah
in retrospect ishaam right now is
probably playing that line for his
kids and being like look eminem said
shout out to eve
yeah cool man yeah for sure i know also
kind of like you know kind of set a lot
of that ground work for the ice
he was in high school doing that [ __ ]
selling out shows wow
that's [ __ ] crazy man
i gotta ask you your
opinion because i have a controversial
opinion about this matter oh [ __ ] okay
so the controversy i am i am a part of
the crowd that believes
that machine gun kelly
won the battle against eminem okay
now i'll give you my reasoning and then
i want you to give me your thoughts on
it
i feel like
mgk
should not have stood a chance right i
feel like the fact that anybody even
the fact is even a question to me means
mgk one now lyrically did eminem rap
better on kill shot of course he did but
in my opinion
the better dis record was the mgk dish
record
and i feel like
eminem is
probably the greatest emcee of all time
when it comes to putting words together
i mean
and so to me it was like the fact that
mgk who's not known to get down like
that the fact we even
anyone's even having a debate about it
means he won right
how do you feel
[Music]
i feel like
when a guy is
you know playing basketball and
they playing the chicago boards tonight
and you got to guard jordan mm-hmm
and you do all right against him you
shut him down and you usually score
50 at night but tonight he scores 35
i think it's a win-win for you
so i just think that
i'm just glad i think i'm just glad mdk
did all he did all right man he did good
he should
he should applaud himself he he made him
a good rap man that's what i feel i'm
like yo man i'm saying but get get out
of here man before
he get mad he got in and out
in the hole man
and i'm i'm actually and i was very
happy that
that he pulled that out of m at this
area's career yeah because i was like yo
eminem just dropped a dis record was it
2019 yeah 2018
like this is amazing
like the fact that like he was at least
able like the fact eminem responded was
even if he got washed it's like bro am
responding to you you're on the artwork
to the song right right like you know
what i'm saying like
to be honest you ain't think you had it
in him did you
who mgk before he did that you ain't
thinking yeah
i'm i'm listening to his previous [ __ ]
i mean i would say this about mgk i am
pretty
i would say i'm like pretty friendly
with with kells and i feel like he
doesn't he ain't no sucker i mean i know
i feel like i knew i knew mgk wasn't a
sucker i i i know he ain't a sucker i
know i know [ __ ] that you [ __ ] with in
cleveland and he's an amazing performer
and lyrically he he does his thing and
so when i heard the the rap devil [ __ ] i
was like oh i mean you know okay this is
cool like
but i was like when i saw the artwork to
kill shot i was like oh it's [ __ ]
it's about to get ugly
it's about to get ugly but then i came
away from kill shot saying ah okay i
don't know
if you know and to me the fact i even
did that was like okay well like like
you said it was like kind of like you
know it was a little bit more un a
little closer than people expected and i
think in in that in that term in the rap
game it's like yo man mgk you you kind
of came away with this
what you think about games this
i thought it was a bit much
i was uh i think game is first of all
his album is dope
he's got a lot of great records on that
one
um
i think um
i think
game with the eminem thing feel it just
feel it felt like a nice way to stir up
some [ __ ] for an album coming out
right i'm not sure uh i just felt like i
couldn't get past the
the eminem voice i know i know game can
i know he can rap better than that you
know i know i know he he's a he's a
problem you know what i'm saying of
course
as a battle rapper you know what i'm
saying i got us in the lyrics
i was waiting for the
okay i feel like that was a little nice
little cute intro to me it was like it's
a ten minute song right he never got out
of that though so it's like he stayed in
that
he stayed in
that marshall's body for the whole 10
minutes yeah i think if you're going to
make a 10-minute record like when you
when we gonna get a game well because
what i'm thinking is he he had another
one of those he had a uh when he was
going against 50
game had a 300 bars freestyle exactly so
we know you can do it you heard that one
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy of course and
that's what happened god damn that [ __ ]
was great he had the gu not [ __ ] so i i
mean like i think i wasn't the craziest
fan of of it uh i think that the album
is dope i just think that like it was
probably
probably could have left that one off
yeah man and then i'm sure i mean i'm
not sure he like game is the type of guy
who stands on his own like at all times
so i'm not sure he gives a [ __ ] about
what people think of it or his
relationship with eminem he stopped he
stopped caring about that a long time
ago right right
for sure so yeah i mean so you weren't a
fan
of that song no no no no i think i think
you could have did it better yeah or
stack quote that better
what'd you say or statco could have did
better what are you trying to say
hey statco is a good friend of mine
he's a good friend of mine too man we
all know are you saying statco helped
write the song yeah i ain't saying that
man i shout out the game
listen i have to say this because i was
in the studio a lot with the game while
he was making this out he was like there
were no ghost writers in there i'll say
that
but stat quo is an amazing writer yeah
former uh
aftermath i think about those green
lantern mixtape days oh man oh
it's good times man yeah i missed the
mixtape era that's my favorite did we
should bring mixtapes back or they still
nice it's over man it's over dsp's
ruined it because now you have to get
everything cleared oh for real yeah
imagine if you put a mixtape up wrapping
over 25 like when the doji united tape
so they're wrapping over everyone's
beats like so what do what about put out
a mixtape you could put it on that pith
or soundcloud yeah the problem is the
people aren't there anymore
oh okay so it's like if you did that
you'd be it'd be kind of like you your
best bet would be to put those on
youtube because the people are on
youtube and you could put up that kind
of [ __ ] on youtube okay
so like i would say youtube
because then if you put it out for free
somebody's going they're just going to
steal it and register the song for
yourself right would they yeah they do
that yeah yeah if i put out a song right
now
for free
but
actual song or a song of you is this
someone free i'm just giving it out like
i ain't registered with districts no you
should definitely do that i'm saying but
if you don't because back in the day
when
when future not only putting the
mixtapes out they wasn't registering
correct like songs so people were taking
the [ __ ] no those are actual songs i'm
thinking about traditional mixtapes
where you're rapping over oh yeah other
people's speeds like i'm thinking like
how 50 was remix in every hot record
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
was hopping on instrumentals like yeah
it's a headache now yeah no not for sure
but now if you're putting out a free
project yeah you have to happen on dsps
man you got to put distro kid tune corp
whatever you're doing like
you know it'd be still like you said if
you ain't going to monetize it someone
else is going to grab it off the
internet
and they're going to and they're going
to claim it what do you think about
rapper sound industrial kid
well district is not a label so they
can't sign the distro kid i'm saying
like i think that if you're established
rappers not not not
i'm not mad at it think about it are you
cool what is the thing distro kit is a
distribution platform right
uh
there's distribution companies where
their business model is they take a
percentage of whatever you upload and
then there's distribution companies like
tunecore and distrokid where you pay one
time
it's up right so to me if i'm an
independent rapper
and let's say
i have 10 songs on my album with 10
producers
that can get
uh
complicated taking care of everybody
if you sign up for that distro kid
you just cut everybody in on the splits
just be like yo what's your sign up for
digital kit account you're going to get
your percentage
and then they do they handle the [ __ ]
grunt work for you you know what i'm
saying is there new [ __ ] on distrokid uh
no
nope it's on
a label
damn i smoked too much that's fine
i'll turn the label what is it called
oh down in nashville though
what does it shift
is it shift
hey
texas just uh go call this guy
tell him uh we'll be right around 3 30 3
45.
what's the guys
um
have you done the distro kid [ __ ] or the
tomb core [ __ ] um
nope not yet i think i put out one song
dude the thing about that [ __ ] is like
one of my artists it's very very easy to
like take care of everybody yeah yeah i
i um get
like the little splits all the time from
like collabs yeah so if you do very
easily if you do a feature for somebody
and they're on distro kid they could be
like yo what's your distro account i'm
going to cut you in like whatever the
percentage i get them all the time
that's that's that's dope so that's why
it's dope and like
i i [ __ ] with just stroke kid it's it's
very like you hit upload and that and
they they handle the splits and that's
it so you can't expect like to you know
you got to pitch your own playlist you
got to do all that yeah but in terms of
like
the
usability of it is great yeah yeah just
hit upload upload your artwork boom boom
boom pay once yeah and you're in there
man yeah i like your importance you feel
like all these independent labels be
lying about marketing budgets too what
they might go digital kid yeah man we're
gonna spend a hundred thousand on
marketing well this is how much you can
give me up front my phone notice the
problem no
nowadays
the problem is nowadays
what is marketing exactly so if they
tell you they're gonna spend a hundred
thousand dollars on marketing well let
me audit what that 100k went to right
because they could say well we did a
hundred thousand dollars in let's say 10
000 of it went to
a youtube buy yeah okay well did it go
to a google did it go to a google buy or
did it go to you buying fake views and
then you're pocketing the difference
right because that's what a lot of these
[ __ ] are doing
is they'll tell artists
that they're
we did a google ad buy on the video or a
youtube ad and
instead they drop half of it on fake
views and then keep the other half it's
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] going on man
you just gotta audit the [ __ ] out of all
these [ __ ] it's like someone
tells you oh yeah we spent this much
you're not recouping like yo let me let
me i need to see where exactly where
that money went labels hate to get
ordered they'll do anything
stop from getting older like wait you
charged me
ten thousand dollars to edit a song and
make it clean what the [ __ ]
that was that was happening with a good
friend of mine uh
who's a great rapper
who has a bunch of giant red hair
where he was signed to a label and they
were they were doing that kind of [ __ ]
where they were like he'd be like yo how
am i not recouped and you'd be like well
yo you guys charged me x amount of
dollars for this for this for this weed
is recoupable
weed yes sir what does that mean
if they buy with the label spin wheel
you gotta pay it back
really yeah
that sounds like some og [ __ ]
with the label back in the day like when
you guys are working on [ __ ] like when
you're on interscope would they pay but
they buy weed
oh yeah hell yeah all that come out of
the bus yeah anything to keep you
[ __ ]
doing these interviews
wow yeah yeah
that's crazy i saw um
amsterdam oh let me shut up man
oh yeah amsterdam right yeah so the
prostitutes be uh recoupable as well in
amsterdam um i played for my own horse
i'm just curious
if you go to if you go to the red light
district
on a promo tour
can you invoice the label for the
prostitutes i think you can
at least back then you probably could
have no nowadays you can't let's be
honest nowadays that's not happening i
don't know i paid for oh one
yeah yeah
have you done the new the amsterdam
thing i've never been like at the
brotherhood yesterday amsterdam thing
yeah every time i went there how was it
i was
i want to get you i better give you a
fake ass answer
um
[Music]
the experience was cool
but i'm like i'm like i'm one of them
dudes that like
so like these girls are in the window
and
they like in these apartment buildings
when you walk up the stairs they tell
you what number they are like what
number are you i'm a number 16. and you
know you're gonna knock on her door
she's like in a [ __ ] closet basically
with some lights and [ __ ] so
you then you look and then she got like
a thousand condoms in her dresser and
baby wipes over here so
you know i i gotta feel like i'm being
loved like i gotta fight you my
girlfriend
i need to look in your eyes looking at
your soul
you know i'm not gonna lie that
surprises me that that's
just based on like who i think you are
off of the
music would not expect that i'd expect
you to be like yeah bro [ __ ] 99 had
11 prostitutes in one room on the red
light district so so so i didn't coke
off my dick
off my ass inside of my [ __ ] anyway
jesus you got a chick blows coke up your
ass no no that sounds that sounds
sketchy i rap about it yeah
it sounds like a [ __ ] you watch the
beginning of snowfall season one oh yeah
where the chick dies because they yeah
or is it the guy that dies the guy died
because the girls were blowing cocaine
up his head
so i did it a lot of times but i never
really busted a nut doing this [ __ ]
because it would i felt like it was
it was fake like you know what i'm
saying that's fair
so it was hard for you to like reach
full climax messing with women you paid
for it
i mean just and then i feel bad for i
feel like she was a slave or something
yeah because you see you you see 50
condoms on the [ __ ] she got a bowl of
condoms and
wipes over here i like to point out guys
her beds on the floor this is a great
opportunity to just point out bizarre is
a great guy
obviously a character on these records
you care yeah i was trying to rescue
them girls man
i'm going to start a foundation for them
man dedicate my next check to appreciate
y'all watching but listen our partners
at blue chew they got you handled fellas
and etc whatever you are they got it if
you got a dick blue chew is for you
because they will make sure your dick
performs at all time levels i mean like
lebron his first three seasons with the
heat type levels i mean your wife will
thank you for it everybody will thank
you for it [ __ ] even if you just take a
blue chew and jerk your dick it's a it's
a stronger jerk i swear to god
stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure you're gonna
be beating your dick like i stole
something
so what you gotta do is go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg right now and
you're gonna get your first month free
and this is the great thing about blue
chew the same active ingredients as
viagra and as cialis
but you don't got to go to the doctor's
office yeah who wants to go hang out at
the doctor's office and be like hey doc
you got some [ __ ] pills for me nobody
wants to do that no you sign up at blue
chew use the promo code bootleg and
you're getting your first month
delivered to your door
in discreet packaging i'm telling you
you're going to thank me later all right
if you've gotten blue too already just
dm me tell me just just dm me no photos
just tell me how you know let me just
tell you it's [ __ ] amazing our
producer cyrus's daddy 70 took the blue
chew he's [ __ ] just beating down all
the senior citizen [ __ ] available in
arizona right now so go to bluetooth.com
use that promo code bootleg or just hit
the link in the description of this
video let's get back to the interview yo
when uh you had mr cartoon do your belly
okay uh one of the most iconic
rap tattoos ever yeah
was that on tour yes yes yeah yeah so
which tour was this anger what anyone
management tour was it the first one
i'm not for sure
but uh
man this dude was she was touring he was
doing everybody so
you know he was so booked up that you
know what i'm saying like
i had to make it i made an appointment i
think he had just did 50. he was
tattooing everybody and everybody he was
talented every day somebody was getting
teddy
so it was my time he was gonna do my
stomach
and uh he said what do you want i said i
want to i want to collage detroit i want
the buildings in the background the
coney islands liquor stores the pit
bulls
they're just grimacing traits okay
so he drew it he drew it on me first
and then i i had to go perform you know
because he says big festival and [ __ ]
overseas so i went and performed rock
the show sweated it off came back and
i didn't know that the worst thing in
the world you could do
is get a tattoo with open sweat and
pores oh so before i asked him i said yo
yo
is this tattoo gonna hurt
he said no man you know you're good
you're good
so then when he started doing the [ __ ]
like everybody pulling their cameras out
and [ __ ] cause they're like i'm like
that's a tough place too i said i
thought you said this [ __ ] wasn't gonna
hurt
he said yeah
it's not gonna hurt me
damn yeah so i just i had to sit there
and pain bro that [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
crazy man but
i was told they tell me once you start
you can't stop
that that'll
well imagine you
torn with half a tattoo on your belly
they would have said that's bizarre i
couldn't get away with it yeah that's
true
no but i had to do it man they would i
would have been a [ __ ] if i would have
finished it right yo back then um when
drugs were like safe to do like how
crazy did the drug use get like at the
peak like peak d12 days like was it
crazy because like we always hear about
eminem and like his issues obviously
shots of him has he's been sober for a
while it got pretty crazy
yeah i mean [ __ ] we all have fun but uh
i just remember getting crazy like
at the crazy spot in like amsterdam
you know it was like was it like ecstasy
was it coke like because that's like
back then that was like peak like x days
right next days yeah i i wasn't really
[ __ ] with the cocaine vicodin yeah
viking him
anything we can [ __ ] get your head
tylenol p.m [ __ ] town
p.m whatever jesus
robert
said whatever but
no man amsterdam was that spot man it's
shroom shrooms don't forget about
shrooms yeah shrooms are still great
yeah i didn't cancel the
two shows off of shrooms what happened
uh i couldn't do it
[Laughter]
which were these solo shows were these
d12 shows yeah so you just got and then
uh one time i did some shrooms in st
louis
and uh marshall uh
seen me he said i was like five miles
away from the venue
and they was coming back from sound
check and they see me walking on the
side of the road
and they stopped me and they said yo
where the [ __ ] are you going they said i
said i was going to join a gang
[Laughter]
off of shrubs so yeah i left the shrooms
alone man
so when you canceled
i enjoy shrooms yeah
i got some gummies for if you want
something
yeah okay well [ __ ] it i'm back
so before you uh when you when you when
you canceled the shows was it just
because like you were you were having a
pretty serious
emotional moment was it a trip you know
one was shrooms one was edibles idioms
are the worst edibles do me worse than
shroom of course they do because they're
they're the devil yeah and that's how i
feel eating weed is the worst [ __ ]
anyone can do yeah if you eat why why do
you think that i just think if you eat
too much weed you're [ __ ] yeah like
it's over for you like
it's like a different effect from
from smoking it's totally different so i
guess so when you eat it there's some
compound that your body breaks it down
and like activates like a psychoactive
chemical that's a lot more stronger than
if you feel like i'm on shrooms but with
no control yeah that's what i'm saying
no when you eat too much weed man [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is rough
it is like panicking it's i've puked
i've like like like you said when you
eat too much shrooms
you might trip or you might really like
get into like a wormhole of your
thoughts yeah just go chill off
somewhere but you you're not like i
don't at least personally me yeah i i
feel like i've never been out of control
i feel like on edibles
there have been times where i felt like
i couldn't move my my legs like i went
to a i went to
i would say i wouldn't sleep at a bus
stop one time yeah like i can't move i'm
inaudible right right i had a uh i had
to cancel the show and that how i did it
the promoter
uh was in the it was in flint oh my bad
it was in flint and the promoter uh was
in the lobby
and uh i called my royal manager ola
and uh all of my all the guys that was
with me and we all met in the hallway
and i looked at them and i said yo
i'm not gonna be here to perform tonight
and it was like what
they said promoters in the lobby i said
i know man i can't do this i was like oh
pull the car to the back of the hotel
and i'm gonna go down the [ __ ] stairs
so he can't see me and leave
and everybody was like what the [ __ ] but
my boy old love he's crazy too so
so by him being crazy he's seen the
crazy in my eyes and said
okay cool
hey and he got me out of there man did
you get this
back
nah
[Laughter]
shout out to my man reflect holla at me
man i'm gonna do a free show for y'all
makeup man how long ago was this uh
about 10 years ago oh yeah well i'm sure
he's not weird
i'm sure he's already took the l he's
already accepted the l
[ __ ]
he ran off with the deposit man out the
back door man the shroom i mean the
edibles did it man the edibles are the
worst shrooms are cool because like i
think shrooms like if you like you said
that was i shot that king gordy did that
actually
he told me see he he makes he he uh him
and his partner they
they do their butter for like two weeks
until it looks like tar
hmm
so and they used like the og kush the
the power for sure they can use
and uh
i had chicken edible before
like maybe a week before and i had and i
had
went crazy on his edible
so then this time he said yo these ain't
ain't that strong like that they just
regular you know i'm saying you're good
i said you sure man
he said yeah and then after hour kicked
in i looked at my [ __ ]
i thought you said that they wasn't that
strong and they just busted out laughing
and thought this [ __ ] was so funny like
you [ __ ] idiot
the promoter in flint didn't think it
was funny man
please man please forgive me man
[Laughter]
oh my god that [ __ ] is crazy yeah um
derek you know if he never canceled the
podcast because he was uh
nah
so the highest i ever been in my life
was at a yellow wolf ritz show oh my god
shout out to roots and i ate um
i ate a
whole brownie that i did that's like i
was 20 14 13. i didn't know i was
supposed to eat the i it would taste so
good yeah it's a little piece
so it wasn't even like a big big brownie
it was like a like a little square yeah
and so uh
i ate it and like an hour goes by i'm
like on ritz's bus everything's cool
yeah we're chilling and i don't i don't
feel nothing
so he's like y'all i'm about to go on
stage so we follow my game i'm gonna
watch it from the from the crowd or
whatever cool so as soon as he starts
performing
it hits me like a [ __ ] semi-truck
right you're right
i could not move my legs damn i felt
like i was planted into the ground
like
i've
not only that
every like have you ever been so high
that you felt like your senses were
heightened yeah yeah for sure so i'm in
this concert
it's probably
800 people there and i felt like i could
hear everybody
no matter how
far they were
i could like hone in on somebody at the
bar like 200 feet away from me in the
middle of a concert and hear exactly
what they were saying right and then i
look on stage and next to ritz's ugly
ass is a [ __ ] cartoon garfield cat
with [ __ ] dollar signs like slot
machines dollar signs like going and
stopping and i'm just i grab my boy and
i'm just like
bro i need you to carry me out to the
back stage
so my my best friend geo had he like
picked me up like a band i'm mine this
is my hometown people know who i am
so i get carried like a baby to the
couch on the side of the stage
bro and like for some reason every time
i
heavily
do too much when it comes to shrooms or
weed edibles
the [ __ ] that would
that
would happen to somebody who's [ __ ] up
happens in front of me like
dude this native american dude
with a whole [ __ ] headdress like
legit and you know how natives love
[ __ ] like ritz and yellow wolf and
like that you know that that world
around i love drinking too yeah they do
god they do shout outs they got livers
on there
um no so this native american dude i'm
on the curb right outside of the doors
club red and tempe and i'm like hunched
over the curb like i just got him puking
everywhere and this [ __ ] native
american dude
with feathers
your bootleg kev i look up
i said
[ __ ]
wow
i look at my boy george
and mind you
not the best thing to say but i was like
yo is this indian [ __ ] real
and he was like yeah i'm real what do
you mean i was like bro i'm tripping
balls right now
what's up
right then
the indian dude's standing here
shout out to yellows uh road manager at
the time his name is brooklyn he was a
very violent guy they drag some [ __ ]
dude from the crowd out and they're
beating the [ __ ] out of him like three
feet in front of me i start throwing up
while the indian guy's there while this
guy's getting beat up it's all happening
at the [ __ ] same time
i'm [ __ ] ritz ritz is there laughing
smoking a cigarette it's just the worst
it was one of the worst nights of my
life
damn
sorry man and then i ate i ate an edible
uh two months ago my new house first
time i had edibles in like two years i
was like you know no no maybe like a
year
and i had uh or is there a grit bro i'm
curled up on the couch bro my wife and
her friend are upstairs dying because i
am curled up on the couch freaking the
[ __ ] out
i'm trying to find something to put on
tv that'll like put my mind at ease yeah
first i tried family guy then i'm like
nah then i just put on like ocean noises
right oh my god he was there
and i went in the back i went in the
bathroom and chucked everywhere oh
something about eating too much edibles
always puke oh you always get sick
i eat up a storm man
yeah or or that or you'll just be
like when i s when i hit dabs that's
when i eat when i like smoking dabs
action bronson smoked me under a [ __ ]
wiz khalifa [ __ ] put me in light so
don't don't do a dab with him you're
happy he he's going to intentionally try
to get you out of here that's what
actually bronson did early dab days too
so this was like before everyone knew
about dabbing like that
he was like oh you haven't dabbed yeah
he's like so he gives me one he's like
no no you gotta take a big hit it's not
that serious take a big hit so i took a
bacon it's exactly what how weak it did
[ __ ] terrible right so he's like no
no now you got to try a flavor i got
this whole thing on film it's great he's
like no no now you got to try a flavor
so i hit it again
three hits in a row i do oh he didn't
giving control of three years [ __ ] it
was mac miller
action bronson a chance to wrap her on
tour and that was the one i was [ __ ]
high out of my brain stand bro watching
mac miller on stage bro i was just like
this is i was probably the third highest
i've ever been shout out to
bronson man wow who uh who are you a fan
of man like what artists right now
are you really like just
kudos
oh he's coming from the city or no no no
in general period oh man
[ __ ] [ __ ] damn i gotta think about it
oh man hold on i'm a homeless fan duh
uh i like naruto wait nardo's fight yeah
i want to sound typical
i don't think people would expect you to
say that yeah yeah donald wick i like
him
uh i like uh
damn i know i'm about to [ __ ] his name
well
but i'm gonna try to get it right uh
the kid that'd be doing shows in his
backyard look russell i was just at his
house last weekend okay
it was amazing okay met his mom his dad
was cooking i've known the russell for
about a year and a half but okay it was
dope
how is this set up is this it's
literally it's really odd the house that
his mom him and his dad and his i think
i don't know if his sister lives or not
but yeah um the house he grew up in
he built a
venue in the backyard there's
bleachers on each side
and then there's like a pergola
and
200 people
in the backyard rocking wow his dad's
making barbecue
it was amazing it was like one of the
most like inspirational
was just like this is [ __ ] this is
crazy
right wow and he's very like when
[ __ ] say they're independent
not not you ain't independent he's
independent right like he's really
it's him it's it's like his team is
super small i mean i went into his
office and he's in the house like again
this is the house he grew up in right
he's got his office and he's got a white
board just with everything playing the
what instagram posts are going up for
the day like it's it's crazy it's
inspiring wow the russell's dope
super and he could wrap his ass off
right shout out to him he'd be saying
some ill [ __ ] yeah i like larry june too
larry june is fire larry june's doing
his thing
running it up right now when you see
these wack rapper lists i know you
talked about the uh the gilly thing
before but when you see these lists
you're always on the list
how do you genuinely feel about that
oh that's that's why that's basically
why he got a gun came out you know i'm
saying
that's why i had to get back in my bag
you know what i'm saying
um i i don't
i don't like it you know what i'm saying
like
i think i'm a a comedian rapper but
you know i think
it goes back to the just
just saying anything even if it ain't if
you don't if it don't rhyme or it's just
crazy or just playing that role so like
you were playing it like i think what
people what you said earlier like you
were legitimately playing a character
indeed yeah yeah right right
so here yeah so that's that's why i'm
here to change it that's why i'm
literally here right now
in your face so you're like yo i'm tired
of these lists so outside of your guy
with the six cats and the four dogs and
the children ah fall balls and that's
how the [ __ ]
that was also a motivating factor for
you to get back in your bag like i'm
tired of this [ __ ] yeah yeah for sure
for sure yeah i i i think i didn't put
too much work in a lot of people don't
know i i am a battle rapper i started
off from the hip-hop shop that's why i
met marshall
if i was a whack rapper they wouldn't
never put me in d12 because d12 was a
hand-picked click
of battle rappers yeah yeah you know
what i'm saying so um yeah so
you know i think you know once we got in
the industry
we kind of like had to find our way you
know what i'm saying like all that [ __ ]
was kind of like an accident even the
shower cap started off as a joke and
then it just became they just stuck this
[ __ ] with me
i mean it worked yeah and it worked you
know and i'm grateful for it but now
it's time to show [ __ ]
that i you know i can rap man he can't
put me on a [ __ ] list with uh
or snow or
which snow you know no the informers
know no you're not not snow from uh
texas uh
informer informer yeah that's no yeah
i don't even know what i don't even is
he a rapper i think he's a rapper i
think they were just high
who's your top three
bizarre who's your top your top three
worst rappers of all time
my top three worst rappers of all time
oh my god let me think about that
oh
i'm gonna i'll give you mine just okay
yeah
to me
playboy cardi [ __ ] god awful okay i
don't get it saw him live it sounded
like he was having a [ __ ] seance on
stage
his fans are crazy it can be the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
playboy cardi is definitely taking the
cake for me
i think technically speaking
i mean
i enjoyed soaked the shockers and music
vastly but
when you go back and listen now you're
like oh
that was interesting why why and then
you got to start thinking about guys
like uh
little zan
damn what is that little zam's terrible
oh man
what was it just you just don't
understand him no no i get the like he
had one record that was dope okay okay
but his [ __ ] sucks
he's stacked quote will tell you his
[ __ ] sucks and he will sign a sack stack
quote yeah we'll tell you damn his [ __ ]
was like he he just never was focused
enough to like make music a priority so
the music that i
outside of that skittle song like i just
thought he was just a god off of ours
all right
damn i'm trying to think of a god offer
already man
you you think anybody i'm trying to
think of somebody
what about anybody from like a rapper's
crew i'm trying to think who was a part
of qbc oh surprise
who probably fuji
really horrible horrible okay yeah we
put the horrible tag on prize yeah okay
surprise
yeah
no disrespect though
i know you're probably gonna come after
me man i want to battle there was the uh
who was the guy who was naz's bodyguard
big hawk big record horse
yep horse
bodyguard
he's a horse's wack
was there someone in
murdering
is it murdery
i don't know you know what though
there was some shitty rappers back in
the day man there were some bad
yeah i think we i think i think sophie
shocker
suffices for for my 90s
you gonna go with the shocker like
i had a no limit chain too so it hurts
me oh
i don't know man
it was for mystical the chain was from
no the chain was for ghetto dope
that was hey shout out to master p yeah
maybe not the best rapper i'm trying to
figure out classic album though
yeah yeah yeah charge it to the game
great outfit yeah i mean listen to the
song is whack i'm just saying he was
[ __ ] maya so we can't even give him
that he was [ __ ] maya in 99 so yeah
shout out to no i said it so you can't
say it but yeah yeah damn you can see it
yeah so who can you say
um anybody from psychopath records it
was just terrible how about the whole
[ __ ] label i said
i didn't listen to a lot of that [ __ ] my
cousins are into that [ __ ] so maybe i
just am not versed enough but i know
some of that [ __ ] like
my cousin would be listening to like a
blazer dead homie album or something and
it just sounded like noise like bad
noise like it sounded like if my dad
tried to rap type [ __ ] you know oh my
god
there was the other guy who was like the
native dude with like the um braids
yeah just terrible oh my god just
terrible twist is cool right there all
right yeah yeah
twist is cool but i cp had some cool
[ __ ] you know great malenko was like the
only album i think i've ever really
listened to and it was like it was all
right
but yeah now those are yeah pretty much
like everyone who wasn't twisted or icp
on psychopathic records we could
probably let me google
the worst 50 rappers and she would
there's a list that just came out
it is am i on it again
[Laughter]
it just went viral i just saw it
uh new list oh this is
here it is
worst rappers list
so little yachties on it yeah lil
yachty's not garbage i love little
yachty silk the shocker is number one
i'm gonna open it
oh yeah so i'm opening it right now okay
little yachty number two that's [ __ ]
cap
master p3 oj the juice man
[ __ ] little flip cap little flick
could wrap his ass off yep
little pump there's an argument to be
made yeah definitely smoke perp argument
to be made
six nine
i would say he's terrible he made some
bangers diddy's on here
walk a flock of that's [ __ ] coiler
ray birdman
birdman has too much music that he's
rapping on that i actually thoroughly
enjoy
vanilla ice
kid boo
god awful rapper who's kid boo he's the
guy who pretended like he was cloned in
some clown clown arrow rap [ __ ] it was
terrible yeet
you know what
the worst rapper of all time might be
yeats
this new kid yeet his [ __ ] is
horrible but the kids love him so maybe
i'm old benzino
benzino
how do we not think of him i i never
listened to his music nobody did
you can't eyes no applause to fire yeah
blue face cardi little b oh you sit
there with nick kenny oh no nick cannon
that's my dog man i can't say no comment
yeah yeah you won't get them a while now
i'm gonna say i wanna see nick cannon
[ __ ]
chingy had some bangers though saint
luna chicks
iggy
iggy azalea maybe designer maybe no
designer anyway
he's not not white yeah he all right
yeah
i ain't gonna put him in the wac
category
french montana then you ain't twins mike
jones little uzi flow rider slash
pitbull
this list is crazy this list don't know
what they talking about petey pablo okay
gucci mane relax
exactly
tony yayo relax i love thoughts of a
predicate feeling tom mcdonald who is
that he's the white guy the mega rapper
i'll sign i'll go sign that
actually there's a lot of weird like
maga rap going on right now that's
probably the worst [ __ ] ever so
i would i would just like to continue my
beef with these guys and say what adam
calhoun and all those guys are the worst
rappers of all time
the absolute worst
i see a list they got uh come back come
at me in the comments bro they got a
little b [ __ ] weirdos
little b
the base guy who can't disrespect the
base guys
he'll put a curse on us
gutter gutter
gutter gutter from uh from young money
was actually not a bad rapper
uh
i would say so i mean literally i would
say something shocker is
you're not on this list
yeah i might step my game up a little
bit the album works
i think we off the blizz
they got playboy cardio in here
yeah playboy cardi they got nelly on
here yeah nellie's incredible relax iggy
i get it you can't put future on this
list future's one of the best rappers of
all time in my opinion yeah somebody
just made up a list somebody at home
with nothing to do man yeah shout out to
uh them we gotta stop the interview tell
you about our partners at odd socks well
first of all let's check out the brand
new collab
look at these the bootleg kev sock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
gonna figure out a way to give them away
though uh but look odd socks the most
comfortable socks in the world um and
the best thing about odd socks is
they're our family man i've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and i will not wear anything else on my
feet like i swear to god i'm about to
take my shoe off i'm going to take the
look what is this
it smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's awesome basic you
know what i'm saying we [ __ ] with odd
socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about nickelodeon
shout out to patrick [ __ ]
cheez-its
baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little pop-tart underwear yeah i
mean
yeah these are the odd socks basics all
right so if you go to the website right
now order you some underwear order you
some socks use the promo code bootleg
kev that's one word all together bootleg
kev and you will save 20 off at checkout
go to
oddssoxofficial.com one more time that's
oddssodgeofficial.com promo code bootleg
kev and you will save 20 off your order
of course we're presented by odd socks
and we are proud to say so all right
let's get back to the interview um
anything else on the horizon obviously
the album is out but like are you are
you gonna be
torn are you gonna be doing anything
else
um yeah yeah probably gonna start twin
uh first to next year working on he got
a gun to
album um
[ __ ] man we grind i'm working on a
cooking show right now oh what's your
go-to dish
uh macaroni and cheese yeah oh your mac
and cheese got it you got a uh
only fan coming out too you [ __ ] on
there huh [ __ ] uh i'm a lonely man
with an only fan
so are you gonna be on there beating off
i'm a lonely man
what the only fan
i don't understand let's listen to that
cliche i'm a lonely man it don't make
sense
you subscribe
so you subscribe to yourself
have you uh how many uh think about
doing porn though
you thought about it i thought about
couple times has there been any uh
official i'm too shy man
i don't i don't know you think so yeah
i won't let you see in this body yet you
should put it behind the paywall
go crazy on all these things
and [ __ ] right yeah but you also have no
issues
all right what is your tattoo they'd be
like look at his belly that's bizarre
i know
bizarre
nah someone else got the same tattoo for
mr cartoon in [ __ ] 2001.
that's not b man it looks like alter ego
oh
you know these rappers do that wasn't me
hey do you remember the energy when like
50 first came onto shady like oh yeah
like did you guys know that was coming
down the pipeline did you all know that
m was just a fan or like like no no no
no
uh
our m50 security uh was
from the queens no no rm security was
from queens
so they kind of put us up on 50 with the
mixtapes and [ __ ]
so it kind of like
gradually grew on them
you know what i'm saying so you know we
you know he he became a fan but yeah
when he
he definitely changed [ __ ] you know
that had to be like that you had to be
security yeah well now i tell you like i
always tell people like i don't know i
think peak snoop dogg and peak 50 are
like the two biggest things i've ever
seen like hip hop ever yeah like doggy
style snoop get rich or die trying 50.
yeah pandemonium yeah just
oh yeah insane oh that was it that was
it that was in the same time right
yeah it was like i mean and then
everybody and then just m and 50 going
at every [ __ ] buddy's night going at
murdering going in tremaine debris going
in [ __ ]
doing it were you just in like during
that time were you just like openly
inheriting every beef just because [ __ ]
it oh yeah for sure every deal yeah we
got to be on point bulletproof vests
security i'm assuming the murder ink
[ __ ] probably got the most serious out
of all that [ __ ] all of it was serious
but uh yeah it was yeah well the moby
beef wasn't serious
[Laughter]
that might have been a serious one of
all i don't know
if i was gonna kill him no i could i
just feel like that they know that
murdering [ __ ] [ __ ] was getting crazy oh
yeah yeah for sure ashanti caused some
strays in that thing man that [ __ ] was
wild man the sideburn line oh my god
and uh suga like was all
because she was with them
oh man that [ __ ] was that [ __ ] was
serious it had to have gotten
interesting yeah but produce some
amazing hip-hop yeah
yeah a lot of stuff that didn't even
make it to any albums all on mixtapes
all the mixtape [ __ ] was so crazy damn
bringing mixtapes back man
that's like when m he released uh what
was the 20th anniversary he just did was
it for eminem show
yeah
nah now before that he did like an
eminem show re-released and he released
one of the mixtape records that was out
forever but it's on dsps and i was so
[ __ ] excited he just did the curtain
call too and put out some other [ __ ]
but yeah you know well listen man oh
bizarre i appreciate you pulling up bro
oh man thank you for having me man i
look forward to not subscribing to your
only fans oh man
i got two customers so far right and uh
the album uh people can go online and
stream it please go online and get it
right now i just dropped the video call
she worked the night shift
uh was that the one you were just
playing yeah yeah yeah some pretty wild
[ __ ] in there yeah man you know what's
the what's the wildest freaky tale in
that song that you can share on uh with
us here oh
i had a
girl come out here from russia
she told me to
make sure that uh
i'm not
telling my black friend she wanted to
get
uh
listen to the song but guess what he
doesn't remem
you know what
he also doesn't remember his lyrics
the girl from russia wanted you to run a
train owner with 10 of your black
friends yeah yeah we had the obliger was
there going to be
was there a guy there watching like was
there a cuck situation going on oh man
just say this man my one of my homies
tried to get in
but he's uh asian and white and he was
turned down that's interesting
was he there
this guy right here this guy's a [ __ ]
rock so i'm going to party in detroit
with him man oh yeah man you got to come
party with us man hole in the wall bar
yeah we got to take you to the food
exchange man
you get some food yeah i'll be back soon
damn take you to the southwest man
that's where he from that's where the uh
chicanos is at man the chicanos oh yeah
nice yeah southwest there it is man
bizarre appreciate you pulling up bro
all right man appreciate you
[ __ ]
good [ __ ]